the shooting massacre at the high school
in parkland Florida is once again
raising questions about gun violence in
America it comes more than 20 years
after a gunman killed 16 grade school
children and their teacher in Dunblane
Scotland and for Scotland and the entire
United Kingdom to address gun violence
there
here's Roxana Saberi good morning the
outrage over that shooting led to what
became some of the strictest gun
regulations in the world we sat down
with a man who campaigned for those laws
he now has a message for the young
people calling for an end to school
shootings in America each mass shooting
in America echoes in the hills of
Scotland reminding Mick north of his own
past you tend to pick up on things that
relate to what's happened in your own
life
in 1996 he and other parents rushed to
Dunblane primary school after a gunman
armed with four handguns opened fire
there absolutely no I just couldn't
believe something like this is a teacher
and 16 children were killed including
North's five-year-old daughter Sophie
Shiba self five times five times among
the survivors was future tennis star
Andy Murray who's still clearly affected
I think everyone knows extremely prod
the shooting here devastated the town of
Don Blaine and the entire country and
led to a nationwide campaign to ban
private handguns within a year north and
other parents pushed politicians to pass
some of the toughest gun legislation in
the world today in Britain all handguns
and semi-automatic firearms are
prohibited you can only use manually
loaded rifles and shotguns for hunting
or hobbies at shooting clubs like this
one in London service
member Sherman Strobel says getting a
gun license from the police can take
months if I check whether the how many
parking tickets you've had whether
you've ever had a drink and drive the
police will also visit your home to make
sure you store your gun in a safe like
this and may ask your doctor about your
mental health if you've had depression
or anything like that you will not get
the firearms license ever but she's
probably a bit heart but a beretta gun
shop in central London general manager
Tim King says overall the regulations
seem to be working I've been selling
guns for 40 years legally and in that 40
years and none of those guns have caused
a problem my customers are caused a
problem
22 years since the shooting in Dunblane
Britain has experienced only one deadly
mass shooting while the US has had more
than 75 our response in the UK matched
that the culture here which is not one
that particularly wants ownership of
guns in the US the US I still don't
understand what goes on in the u.s.
North has travelled to America to
advocate for tighter gun control in the
US now has a message for the Florida
students calling for more action keep
reminding people what happened to you
don't take any notice of people who say
well you're only teenagers do you think
these kids can really make a difference
I sincerely hope they can he wants them
to know that while tragedy can tear
families apart I'm sure she would have
been proud of me it can also give people
the power to create change in 1996 the
same year as the mass shooting in
Dunblane a gunman in Australia killed 35
people that led the country to pass
sweeping gun reforms Germany did the
same after school shootings in 2002 and
2009 in those countries gun violence has
not disappeared but deadly mass
shootings are very rare Alex
Roxana Saberi thanks Roxana of course
Australian Prime Minister Malcolm
Turnbull was meeting with President
Trump yesterday and was asked at a press
conference about whether the US should
pursue some of Australia's reforms there
was kind of a rejection of casting
similarities between the again there was
the different a different culture at
that point but there's there's a number
of cases there that are worth looking at